[Musique]
ce rêve de genband est pro d'aller à
l'entraînement tous les matins de vivre
du foot c'était mon rêve
il y avait une aisance technique qui
était de ce genre d'aisance technique
qui s'apprend pas quoi ça c'est de
l'inné et de l'acquis si du talent
antoine ils vont le voyez tous les deux
trois mois ce qui a compliqué un 14 ans
à la real sociedad
je tiens à le remercier des je t'aime
enfin déjà pour mon père dit je t'aime à
moi tout seul si compliqué mais là
devant de mort
deux minutes personne encore encore plus
[Applaudissements]
aigri
[Musique]
l'actrice y est différente
[Applaudissements]
champion jours donc faut sauter données
arrivé par hasard
[Musique]
il arrivé tranquille humble il a gagné
ses galons mars à celle ci aurait
récemment les ticos et 180 l'assistante
de soi pour le collectif
le pouvoir ça se donne pas
ça se prend
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]